[موسيقى]
السؤال الكبير انه هل الصيام ممكن
لمرضى القانون العصبي ولا لا والجواب بشكل
مباشر وسريع اي نعم ممكن وممكن يفيد مريض
القولون العصبي
الاكثر مرضى للقولون العصبي تكون معاهم
اوجاع واعراض مصاحبه للاكل ومصاحب النوع
الاكل اللي يتناول المريض فالامتناع التام
عن الاكل هو يعني كان واحد ممكن يفهمك
انما هي ريبوتينغ او اعاده ضبط المصنع
للجهاز الهضمي فالجهاز الهضمي مهما كانت
المشاكل الموجوده به من نوع اكل معين او
نوع البكتيريا الموجوده هو راح يكون راحه
للجهاز الهضمي
تبقى المشاكل اللي ممكن مريض القولون
العصبي يعانيها هي وراء الافطار يعني
شنو واحد يتناول وهاي طبعا تختلف من مريض
المريض
شنو اللي يتناول على الفطور او طبعا على
السحور وهاي تختلف مثل ما قلت من مريض
المريض الاشياء العامه اللي هي السبايسي
فود اللي هي القهوه الاكلات الدهنيه
الثقيله هاي الاشياء ممكن تاثر ممكن تجهد
الجهاز الهضمي وهاي مثبته بدراسات انه
بالتالي راح تكون اعراض اكثر والمريض
القولون العصبي فهاي الاشياء الواحد ينتبه
عليها اللي هي الاشياء اللي المجهده
للجهاز الهضمي الاكلات اللي تؤدي الى تكون
غازات اكثر يعني السكريات الالياف اللي ما
مهضومه هاي الاشياء تاثر بشكل مباشر
وموجود طبعا هاي قوائم
اسماء هاي الاكلات اللي هي تجنبها المريض
بشكل عام بالحياه اليوميه لازم نفسها
يتجنبها عند الافطار او عند السحور
[موسيقى]